yellow and welcome to a new video on
this video is about the last four games
I played at the european club card that
has finished two days ago in Slovenia
and I had a really outstanding start
with two and a half points out of three
which was covered in the first video and
what the goal was to to make my final
international master norm so um with
this good stardom it was important to
what to keep keep the score at least and
try not to lose the game and score maybe
one and a half to two points to to
really finalize that norm I'm going to
the fourth round and we got a pretty a
pretty strong room opposing team we
started with them as a team we started
with a loss in the first round then one
in the second and we made a really
strong 333 draw in the third round was
the Hungarian team so I was a really
really good start and you know first
round we got them the team from Italy
which was composed of for a couple of
experienced Italian international
masters on boards three-year 26 and they
had to foreign players some as as the
top boards and second bottom bottom
Arthur Ottawa Cogan from Israel is rated
2563 so I was glad to to get a strong
opponent again but i think it was not
the most convenient opponent you can get
because
from the preparation angle it was it was
difficult because he basically plays all
openings he plays sorry he plays it on a
regular basis both efore d4c 493 so it
was it was hopeless 22 really guess what
he would play um when I look at the game
now I think I made a mistake there
because um well in case of that that he
plays d for which she did let's do the
first couple of who's plenty for um the
one in case of this move I think it
would have been possible maybe to to
guess what he would play but well after
the game you always know better i'm okay
um let's see what what happened on my
plate d5 well see 4693 and Bishop e7
long yeah this solid line on the start
of this solid line I had prepared for
the tournament and now you went for the
exchange on d5 and Bishop f4 yeah this
is also a line that I recommended for
white in one of my d4 repertoire videos
so it's um it's a pretty logical choice
from his point of view s he also another
default games he played him he also
liked to exchange on d5 so maybe I could
have guessed the den term and did some
more preparation but i'm not sure it
really this game didn't really give me
so much direct problems in the opening
but maybe it would have been better to
to be more prepared for this yep late
night have six here and he went 43 what
one one thing here Blackie made mainly
am
chooses between c6 and 96 and Knight f6
and the difference is that if black
plays not this one but but c6 on one
popular continuation here is III Bishop
f5 which looks at first sight I'm pretty
good for black because you get this
Bishop developed early but then he has
got the option to play g4 and in case of
pitcher / g 6 which is maybe a question
move he can even play edge form because
it's not good to take on h4 on account
of queen bee three and it's it's
difficult to cover both room the b7 pawn
and keep the bishop on h4 protected so I
cannot simply play this because the
bishop is hanging um yeah I don't I
don't like this on setups with reform so
my choice was not f6 and also I did
prepare this because of this kind of
line you played III now which is logical
and now Bishop f5 this is um similar but
it prevents g4 um 11 line that white can
try now is queen bee three after which
knight c6 leads to a very interesting
play white might even grab the spawn but
after that before Black gets really nice
counter play for the pond would be a
little bit too much to go into details
of this variation right so it's it's
okay for blackheads also been played by
him a couple of strong rent masters some
even even Kramnik plated more than once
so it's certainly a correct on sacrifice
and what he played it so entirely
different and he went for probably
should be to here which is rare move
only played a couple of times before and
it's interesting it's interesting try
and the ideas maybe after all to play G
for just prepared reform and it's still
flexible why doesn't really need to play
G for but he can in under the right
circumstances um here played c6 which I
was not sure about in the game because
well this G formals it's a bit
uncomfortable to to face this he played
you for now maybe it's been would have
been an idea two instead of go for this
just just to Castle here and I think
it's questionable then if he once really
wants to play G for now I just a retreat
to his six and then play for our for c75
oops the wrong key and then play for c75
to get some counter play not sure it's
my problem was that I didn't study these
kind of position so so good and and
therefore I lost a really a lot of time
two to get acquainted with this so what
six is still okay um but castling would
have been interesting you know pledgee
form and now it's a very difficult
decision at least for me it was more
difficult decision whether to go to e 60
to g6 and I was aware that Bishop g6
maybe it's somewhat risky but I played
it anyway we should be six is certainly
a bit more solid um we would see in the
game why he should be six is somewhat
more solid bishop g6 very plain edge for
and now went for h5 the computer
actually even suggest to to just play
age six year but I don't like this move
at all but my idea was aged 5 g 5 or
force the 94 yeah I thought that this
should be really ok for black because I
like a bit of space here and it's a good
idea to exchange one night I still think
this was a good idea on one problem with
this kind of porn set up here is that
the h5 porn might be weak at some point
you look at this this configuration or
rather the other way around this can be
can be a problem in the long run
especially if you consider that the
night might come to a f4 as well and
then each wife will be a problem and
this is the reason why putting the
bishop in g6 might might be a bit risky
with the bishop andy sixx i always have
the option just to play g7 g6 so if i
would have gone to e6 this kind of
configuration would have been simpler
but on the other hand i wouldn't have
the opportunity to put the night on you
for so ok he went for f3 here and i
captured c 3 i'm also interesting would
have been night to d6 in order to to get
this i DN think this also should be it
should be ok for black but i took on c3
because um in this kind of setup here i
thought that also would be somewhat
risky for white um this kind of position
because the King doesn't have a natural
place here anymore where it would go
maybe to f2 but this is still a bit area
here ok them 97 now we went for nine h3
and now I played in I think an
interesting move
it's okay but my problem was that I
played played bad afterwards I played
nah def ATM um alternatives are Knight
b6 order to keep an eye on the c4 square
maybe prevent right from playing c3 c4
and also I am I could have castled here
this is a computer move actually um
which didn't really cross my mind at all
because some repealing it looks somewhat
strange to to castle here he well this
advanced pawns and maybe he was the
bishop and then f4 and edge a tribe is
just hanging him I wasn't sure so I
didn't I didn't think about this at all
the computers to give this as equal but
well I actually still like my idea of 9
f8 no he went for c4 on 96 this was of
course the idea for native aid and queen
bee three and now I made a mistake and
serious mistake it still doesn't really
as spoiled the position completely but I
had the correct idea here but I just
made a little calculation mistake here
what I should play here is here at this
point as really castles and I think this
is actually really really fine for find
her black the idea here is in case of
white takes on b7 play Bishop d6y then
nothing needs to take on d6 and then for
instance with a threat of Nazi three
green to g3 it should maybe play king to
have two and then I have a really
interesting compensation for the pawn
with good ideas like rupee a droopy to
you'll note that the bishop when g6 is
always covering this be one square and
white has still problems with his pieces
here this not doesn't have a good square
really because the 96 is covering here
at form and this is really a really nice
position in this concrete oops just have
a look at this I think white needs to to
cover this with the King and then I can
can just take here for instance if he
now captures this be two squares wide
open I think this is already grateful
black um I think in the game I I had the
feeling that white has so little bit
over extended but I just um played this
idea and in the wrong move autumn what I
did I played um Bishop to b6 immediately
after that he captured takes takes on d5
CD files as much I had anticipated and
then he just has the simple move Queen B
5 check and this simple check I didn't I
didn't take into account I was just
thinking about okay if he takes on b7 I
castle and have a similar position as
shown before with rugby 8b to Quincy 3
and so on and this is a brilliant
position if he would take but after this
move I have the problem that I don't
want to play King f8 of course and then
he can't even take on b7 the computer
actually I think this is all a hot so
unclear but I didn't want to go into
this and kinky 7 makes no sense at all
as it takes me seven was check so I was
more or less forced to play m27 now we
went for oxy one and now this this kind
of pawn structure just famous white in
the long term because
I have this weaknesses and just make
couple of my moves I don't have anything
better than exchanging here now
exchanged king is heaven so let's stop
with this position and this is in the
long term somewhat variable for white
because i have two long-term weaknesses
on h5 and also d5 well why it has no
real porn weaknesses he can easily cover
let's say d those pawns it's very
unrealistic that I get some pressure on
the e-file or something and I can I
cannot attract any any pawns of his
while he always has those ideas to to
get the night here which was prevented
the moment okay but he's got also ideas
of maybe night to g3 like this Bishop e2
and then they're formed at the end h5
versus under pressure it's very
uncomfortable to play this position and
actually lost this really quickly which
shows that I didn't defend it too well
but it's it was really really not not
fun to play this but we can look what
what I did wrong in the on the following
moves i started with Rosie 8 which is I
think still okay he went for night f2
which makes sense and because it's not
realistic anymore to go to F forward he
might try to to to reroute the night
this way or maybe maybe this way so nigh
def to it was perfectly logical um um
and now I played played a béchamel phone
I was already am a little bit down on
time and i'm not sure but he played all
his moves rather quickly and which was
really uncomfortable
and I made them seven my plate um and
was based on a wrong calculation he
played to Bishop a phone or which I
expected to get the idea of Bishop b3 n
to attack d5 and my original idea here
was to to play are mobs to play um
Bishop f5 and then when when it was them
at this point I recognize that moves
like rook air-five are very very
annoying here with a simple idea to get
the other look on c1 I cannot play b62
to evict us rook and if i go here he
will play this and this gets somewhat
somewhat ugly i also wasn't sure about
which minor pieces i should exchange and
not exchange um well this looks um yeah
it's not not a nice position maybe it's
it's all holdable me some some way but
it's no fun well I I just went back to
e6 here and all right still it's still
not completely lost something but why
just just can can try on rookie you one
now she doesn't do much with improved to
position a bit and clears h1 for the
night now I decided to exchange and go
for have six which is I think okay now
he made a mistake and the only really
one in the game decides maybe the
opening set up which I think was rather
risky if I would have gone for this
counseling idea at MU 15 I think I would
have gotten a nice position you know
should just take on f6 here
and he played Bishop b3 which is a
slight mistake but I didn't capitalize
on this I was already short on time um I
played a king f king d6 here what I
should have done this is rook d8 covered
this pawn with the rook and then if he
takes on f6 we capture with the king um
this is simply a more interesting way to
defend this with the idea of maybe [ __ ]
dropping the bishop to to f5 or f 7 and
then play either g5 with the idea to get
some counter play with the H porn or try
Bishop remove g6 and then 97 f 5 for
instance let's just use the arrows
something like this if you all all wines
nicely and I get to this and this is
just a tougher defense i played king d 6
now he captured I could have he could
have avoided that if he would just have
captured immediately on f6 instead of
playing Bishop b3 now 9 h 1 we should f7
lagi three and now on I think I maybe
should have just returned to g6 or
something it gets now uncomfortable
really uncomfortable h5 is this week and
they don't really get mine I to to f5
maybe Bishop g6 would have been been
better here this allowed the movie for
immediately and after my next move is
it's lost really a plate b6 I was I was
really short on time now but yeah well
Brooke f8 was a tougher move um for
instance King III he can just simply
improve the position maybe also keeping
in mind that he can always play even
even this maneuver to attack both pawns
so um joinha it maybe they'd say this
and then it's a sort of oops wrong
position I cannot I cannot make a really
good move here for instance if i take on
the form to release the pressure on d5
he might take here and gets gets to see
5 I just lose a porno um that's it's
terrible b6 but b6 was even simply for
white because he got an F for with the
idea of pushing he five I cannot take on
you for of course as this is hanging at
Jeff 7s hanging I went for g8 well II
five check Kingda 7 + f5 and at this
point I resigned as I cannot stop e6 and
I don't have hmm i don't have any decent
move we can just play six and my pieces
are so bad so it's just just lost
position so i resigned yeah the key
moment here really came early my this
move Bishop t6 was some was really bad
um it's it's difficult to say and how I
can hold this position that arise
afterwards but I should really should
have got castling here with with this
line and then this Bishop b6 idea i had
the correct idea i just i just made it
in the in the wrong and the wrong move
order missing this check on b5 um to be
honest I think this position is already
somewhat better for black I like it and
public more let's just not say it this
way because I have a clear plan to make
use of his King position and we cannot
really take on b7 so
this would have been a really good
chance to maybe get something more out
of this game than this torturous
position that I got ya this kind of this
kind of structure am would be
interesting to look at this with the
strong player to to determine which
which defense plan would have been
better yeah I talked to him briefly
after the game and he agreed that this
is really terrible position to to defend
um but we didn't look at it and II take
it also couldn't really tell him but
what would be the the best way to to
defend this um yeah okay this was so
lost in the fourth round but it it
wasn't so so bad in terms of tournament
standings because i already had this win
in round three so these two sort of
evened out um the team did bad in this
round a vm what was the final result I
think we lost one to five or something
they really really crushed us so the
next round meant that we would get some
some easy opposition um and the next
round I can switch colors here if I got
white again we could pattern against the
the White Rose team from from England
yeah they played with Richard pehla
pehla Iran bought one the big one on
writer think he he works for every man
and writes lots of books there and five
players rated rough around her 2250 or
something and my opponent also was rated
like this to 253 name was Paul in Port
Townsend and I could white again hmm and
it was was pretty easy I just needed to
just
I need going to win this game everything
else was really not acceptable for for
the norm hunt I went for a 93 and the
preparation wasn't so easy I had a
couple of games so of him but it wasn't
so easy to guess what what you might
play I think it was clear that it would
be something with g5 so no Kings Indian
or that show something but he played
various set up so I just went with my
usual things interestingly am I got
exactly the same position out of the
Catalan opening which already had in
round three but now he went for c6 the
closed variation of the Catalan was a
pleasant surprise usually am this line
is it's difficult to handle for black um
it is playable of course but you really
need to to know all the ins and outs to
to get a good position end generally
speaking a few people can do that I play
93 here which is possible because of the
move Ottawa c6 he played music snow um
if he takes now on c4 I have the
possibility to play 95 as he cannot
cover this because the pond is just
hanging because the bishop so I can
afford to play Knight c3 here to get the
night on the active post on c3 it be six
now which one fits into the scheme that
black is mu 495 we should be seven that
he form um yeah it was funny at this
point here I think almost and hidden he
thought for I don't know 15 minutes or
something and it was really really
interesting because there is a
well-known trap here
which if would she fell into but it was
really remarkable that he played this
after 50 moves because i was i was sure
that he spotted the trap and was looking
for something else but he still played
it so i could that be the seven which is
sickly a mistake it loses the pawn
actually we will see in the game what
leg should play um is either night 86 or
risky line take on c4 which runs
something like this to grab this pawn
here which is very risky White has great
compensation for the pawn as the Queen
side is so weakened but well it's better
than than the game for sure when you
played knife in his hand which is a
really well-known mistake um white can
can take here and Bishop c6 he takes d5
on our plate it should be seven um just
to show what happens if he takes like
now on saves the piece i have g6 Queen
g2g seven and i'm just a pawn up this
has happened in really a lots and lots
of games even with very strong players
playing black so it's not the first one
to to fall into this he actually won for
Bishop e7 immediately which is similar
but in this kind of position I don't
have the isolated pawn on d4 so I think
this is even worse than the other line
um rook ft 8 and now I made a big
mistake and well the move was bad but it
was also very bad that i played this so
quickly i think it was it was difficult
to
to start thinking right now because
almost before I play to complain simply
you know book moves are well known
things so at this point you already had
spent 40 minutes and i had spent nothing
so this was the first move i was some
thinking about and i played rather
quickly Queenie to which someone made
sense to get the Queen out of the D file
and I think I just relax too much I was
very glad that he made this mistake and
I thought okay I'm I will win this
anyway now but this is a mistake i
should play am I should play just be
three year and we will see now what was
the problem he can he can play clean
before now and this is actually somewhat
somewhat uncomfortable because he just
tries to text c4 and I cannot play b 3
because the night is hanging behind the
development here and I I didn't see a
way to protect this pawn I also didn't
want to play D 45 um let's just have a
look oops because I wasn't I wasn't sure
about this kind of position let's see
for an IG for it it didn't look very
very comfortable to me so I invested I
don't know almost 20 minutes or
something and then came up with Ned b5
which wasn't remove I I really like to
play and but what can you do in now
played a 6 and 9 a-3 this was the idea
to reroute the night from c3 to a 3-2 to
cover this pawn looks ridiculous but
have no no choice otherwise I cannot
return the porn in some way because this
was even leave me with a worse position
whoops a head now looks logical be three
um well I'm I think white is still
better here but it was awful too
to get the night from c3 to a three ya
b3 I think now he makes a mistake and he
goes for a b5 now which looks active and
somehow you always want to play active
lucem when you're in your pond down try
to stay up trouble but I think this is
actually a bad idea because i went for
Bishop b2 now and now it doesn't really
have a choice but to take on c form as
otherwise I might take myself and just
grab be five and then them two pawns up
and this actually gets my night back
into the game and this configuration
here also means um that I have ideas
like this Bishop e3 and 96 so the
problem with my night was solved hmm
sorry so I'm this is this is really a
still fine for me engines it's easier to
play now I think you should have done
something else instead of b5 maybe he
went for a five and no Bishop e3 queen
bee five and queen have six to get out
of the pin and now I just threatened on
96 and now he makes a mistake whoopsie
six and this leads by force to almost
winning end game it's a long line but it
should have avoided this am Bishop e7
rugae and rook c1 and the threatens
Knight a5 it's got a week back around
pink robes back rank this is the thread
I just see a place 25 now which is a
relatively best move now captured
captured 2595 and I
a five this was the problem with this
rook placement because the back rank is
so weak so on read this just to show
quickly cannot capture because of the
maid here and well he captured oops he
didn't capture but played root CA six
and yeah here I'm originally I I saw two
lines here at first I thought I could
just play out night be seven minutes and
then a four next move and it's over but
he's got this annoying move just
postponing to take here and then he
might even play em this one in the
future and I think I cannot hold this
pawn um so I went for something else
knight c6 and this directly transpose us
into a rook endgame yes no choice he has
to take now um takes this neat little
trick so it needs to return takes on d5
85 and this this rook endgame mom is
winning for white I played it very yeah
let's say I made it more complicated
than I needed to really um here I was
also low on time and what I made a
mistake to play too quickly now in the
next couple of moves and then it got
somewhat tricky again I'm king of aids
logical b5 only went for rugby age I'm
not sure this is the best one either
Roxy fire fruit d and king of three and
now in for King e7 and now on two times
I just miss a very easy win I played the
next move I'm instantly I think I didn't
think much about this King III I made
this is as bad i can i can just play at
the check here and this is just
completely winning he needs to go to
maybe here to cover this pawn and then i
can even just push here because of the
week seven drank this is an automatic
win um yeah and it would have been very
easy at ke three let this one Luke c6
check King e7 back i know i can again
give this check but i thought i could
just run over with the king and i went
for this proxy five
and now we enter the position with Luke
a one I think what I did them is still
winning um it would have been much
easier to it to give this check on c7 of
course on Roxie 251 qc3 rook b18b
couldn't approach the palm because this
is a check here check with the king
rookie one would be to back yeah when we
got got this farm that's just now I
cannot make a more progress here with
the King so I decided to take it and I
think this is still winning with the
King cut off from by the rookie em I
think this is so okay what I what I
played maybe I could have done something
simpler but this is winning I'm now just
approaching this pawns on the King side
and and win them and also the deep bonus
it's not free to go so this was pretty
pretty easy win
and now I five is dropping as well yeah
a plate technically I didn't play this
really good but I was really nervous Sam
because it was pretty clear windus that
the chances for the norm but would
increase dramatically this was a
fifth-round only two rounds to go and
well you always do some calculation
beforehand so it was clear if I win this
game that it might be possible to to get
the norm with just one point out of two
games off and I let some circumstances
even have a point of two games would
have been okay but um yeah we lost the
match again so the the next team mum was
even week earned this one we could pad
um with the slogan team from Slovenia
the home home team they had more than
one team but it was one of the the
weaker ones um I got black and my
opponent Sam field master rated 2316
Dennis Doron org you hon um yeah he
didn't have so many games in the
database and but I was pretty sure what
that we would get on an Italian game
here um and well my plan was to to offer
a rather quick draw because it was clear
that two draws would have been okay to
get this in all let's just see what what
happened we got this really standard
line of the of the Italian
rookie one it should be six now this was
move ten and I offered to draw here I
was surprised because he declined ok ok
I'm rated like 70 80 points higher or
something at a great tournament before
thought okay maybe he would just take
the draw and I don't know enjoy the
tournament as a spectator for this day
but ok he wanted to fight I'm still it
so it's a solid position now for black
and just took to gonna be three Mookie
893 d5 so all very logical I'm now I
expected really Queenie to to keep the
Queen's on in case of my exchange on e4
but it just went for before ok a draw
was fine with me so I wasn't looking for
much more to to exchange here rook the
eighth and okay this is another mm-hmm
pair of pieces exchanged King f1 and 98
which is a standard standard maneuver
here maybe get the night to t6 and then
even play f6 at some point to get this
night oops this night moving this is
actually the only real issue with black
position that this night doesn't do much
it is very much restricted by about
these pawns and always needs to protect
d5 so it's a good idea to give you five
some other protection and then make
possible to to move this night he now
surprised me with age form and well my
my instant reaction was that this should
be a bad move um was funny because after
the game he told me that he had seen
this idea and a grandmaster game and I
looked it up and it was it was really
played this is this exact position was
reached before Nana Grandmaster game
the white player was a big trouble again
from a day via rated to 670 or something
and he played also age for his opponent
I forgot the name now I'm also strong
red master he replied um um 96 which are
also thought about but I played
something else and white actually won a
nice game he played h5 now and I had
some really had some pressure long-term
mainly because this can be a nice square
for a night and yeah what is this a bit
a bit better here it's got some space
advantage I played something else at
play Knight f6 which also played this
mother quickly because it seemed very
logical to me to to return the night
here in order to get on g4 because he
has some he needs to play some unnatural
moves now on a g4 is really a threat so
um he now went for night you won which i
think is almost the only really decent
move here the idea is if I am go here
now you can really play f3 there's no
maid or something for instance can give
this check take stakes and then 9 f5
I don't have ended have a good square
here let's say this yeah this Bishop has
no square now only duty to and this is
easily defended son igg4 doesn't really
need too much I don't know went for it
should be six I think this was a good
idea actually I'm let Keaney to now I
now a five this was the idea we should
be six um I needs to take now it's no
good to play b5 let's just say this and
this is this bad for white because of
those weaknesses here the net will get
into play on c69 maybe needs to take now
so he takes a five really was the only
move took with a knight now and this
soft the problem of this office stupid
knight on c6 because the night now has
possibilities to to go on on this week
squares um plate Luke a three now and
down I'd see form yeah this is somewhat
so motivated by the fact that the draw
would be fine so he went rogue a for now
and 95 again with the idea of playing on
night 2 B 3 and then maybe night to see
five so went back we repeated once once
more and now we again avoided the draw I
actually don't understand what he was
doing him because I mean he just is just
playing for win with no justification in
this position um yeah okay might be
three and now I doesn't have much else
than this move takes only three and now
I need to check with the pawn cannot
cannot take here because of this simple
trick
so well this position on evaluated as
some as much better for black and I was
surprised that the computer actually
gifts this is almost equal it's hard to
believe because of the the porn
weaknesses okay they are not so easy to
attack but I mean those weaknesses of
course and this is kind of things but ok
is got some activity ok seven group b 8
need to cover this returns now we get
this kind of position yeah this is of
course more comfortable for black butter
I made a mistake and soon afterwards 9 f
1 h 5 the normal move tool to fix the
pawns here and maybe get them get this
one in later so pretty pretty logical I
think it's you form now yeah and at this
point if I want to play for a win here
which I'm I could I think from a
positional point of view I need to play
a g5 now I had another idea but I
overlooked them something really simple
or forgot something really simple i
played this now with this idea and i
just forgot that he could play Knight c3
to d5 I should have oops here I should
have tried something like this and this
can be can be still annoying for why to
defend to say the least I didn't I
didn't yet analyze this in detail I have
to say I'm I just I just I just simply
forgot that that he could go to go to t5
here
so in this position after 96 I i offered
to draw again after I offered on move 10
and this time you actually accepted okay
the White has has nothing to play for it
just needs to go to a for now and then I
maybe would have played rugby age in
order to answer night d 5 would be five
and it's i think i'd say maybe it's
still somewhat somewhat more comfortable
for black because of the pawn weakness
but white has activity i think yeah
maybe it's equal maybe it's just equal
well I needed to draw here in this in
this game and he took it so I was I was
glad yeah the next term the thing was we
lost this match again the team lost the
match again this time it was so um
rather narrow affair but ok we lost so
in the last round we got the the team
from Denmark um my opponent um there was
rated next game was rated to 2250 and it
was it was easy a draw would be would be
the norm I just couldn't afford to lose
unfortunately I'm somehow I didn't get a
color change so I didn't get white I got
black again but ok would see this game
was I was a quick affair he just play a
play d4 d5 93 9 f6 9390 64 he takes
Bishop before he took on c6 and offered
to draw so hey so yeah I just accepted
of course and was glad to to get the the
norm in the back yeah he told me that he
had already the day before he already
had offered to draw after move 6 because
he wanted to enjoy the yeah
enjoy the other games look at the top
players and also enjoy the weather on
the outside which was understandable you
know he had a great great weather or all
week and so he also wasn't aware that I
needed to draw for the for the norm so
it was really funny and somewhat lucky
that I didn't need to play they all came
usually I should manage to draw a game
um brother some this kind of rated
player but it is a matter of loss and so
on and I was really glad that I didn't I
didn't need to fight didn't need to
fight them so yeah I think overall if
you look at the seven games the key game
really was the game in round 3 where
managed to to beat this guy from Hungary
and rated almost 2,500 and this really
am helped a lot to to to to increase the
rating average and to get some points in
so I could afford the loss worthless
koban in round 4 yeah after all all in
all it was a brilliant tournament as a
whole very nicely done by the Slovenian
guys they're nice really nice playing on
playing holds we had three three rooms
for all the teams and um I can heavenly
recommend to if you get I don't know if
you get the chance to to qualify with
your team or something it's just a great
event so um family recommended to to to
play there if there's the possibility
also if its future tournaments and
addendum in in near you handle the next
one is in Israel in 2012 and I don't
know but maybe it's
future years maybe bring this tournament
closer to you then it's really nice also
to watch and and and look at all the
great players and it was really nice to
just I don't know get a coffee in the
morning and in a cafe outside and you
have all those guys like I don't know
Boris Gelfand or Shiro for those guys
strolling along it's just funny yeah
well thanks for watching and also think
of subscribing to the channel if you
like to get informed about new videos
I'll also do some more 5-minute games
with comentary maybe not today tomorrow
because I'm very tired those seven days
really am really took some some effort
to play and also the journey back was
rather long and so watch out in the next
couple of days for for new and new
videos of blitz games and well yeah
thanks for watching and well up to them
until the next video yeah thanks and why